[Music]
so uh speaking of murder nice murder
a man has quote gotten away with it for
nearly 40 years
wow live the whole life that is that is
a whole life a farmer has been accused
of killing his wife and concealing her
body for nearly 40 years after she
vanished from her home in
worchestershire in 1982
is that is that right worcestershire you
said you said it's smooth i think that's
right right
you said the smooth man yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's where they make the
sauce i think so
just serve say it again we're just sure
nice
to shire we we heard it yeah from
who someone told us you came in so
strong
from who we know how to say it
i just said it all right anyways this
guy's name is david venables i'm just
gonna say david from now on he's 89
years old now let him go let him go
set him free
no 89 let him let him go because his
life sentence would be like six months i
scored man
that's a good that is a high school
that's that's a little bit anyways uh he
appeared at worchester crown court
yesterday uh where he is on trial for
the murder of his wife brenda good prior
to his wife's disappearance the court
heard from prosecutor michael burrows
that uh david had allegedly been having
an affair with a woman named lorraine
but did he get married after lorraine
reportedly cared for david's mother with
the court hearing the affair first begun
uh around 1967.
by lorraine's doubts david's feelings
for her uh and david's feelings for that
it led to an affair cooling off but it
allegedly picked back up again the
months before his wife vanished couldn't
resist lorraine uh divorced her husband
in 1970 so it was a double affair so he
killed his wife for no reason what do
you mean no it's a double affair yeah
it's double because she's her man
lorraine
divorced her man thank you guys yeah
yeah so his wife is brenda they could
have divorced and that's an option but
he decided to kill yeah
so lorraine divorced her husband in 1970
the same year that uh brenda um
discovered that david was having an
affair
and then david allegedly told lorraine
he would divorce his wife however
um it wasn't mentioned when it was
brought up sex was he lying i don't know
she just ran away good thing though we
could get we could get together now
probably yeah
in 1982 david reported his wife missing
to worchester police station news
newspaper clippings detailed david's
statement that he didn't have the
faintest idea where his wife was i don't
know where she went
and she was suffering from depression
the comment led to some people presuming
that she had committed suicide and then
the event a police investigation came up
empty-handed empty-handed so 40 years
goes by
did he did he end up marrying no
laureate
did it even work out they i think they
just kind of kept going with their
relationship and stuff like that but are
they still [ __ ] though that's my
question i don't know he's 89.
he might be like eddie
i mean like nah because i've seen some
porno or some but i mean that's besides
the point no wait finish
no no i'll finish that it's the sentence
bro we can't graze over that yeah what
kind of porno yeah what's going on
there's geriatric porn okay no we are
aware of that but that's not how you
presented it you said i've watched there
is a whole genre of porn
where grandpas have sex with like hot
girls and stuff
and what do we what do you feel about
that i just it popped up on my feet i
didn't look for it so don't blame me do
you feel like they still bring the heat
as geriatrics to me my curiosity is
number one how are they so hard and two
how do they perform with so much stamina
yeah they're really hard so they're
bringing it they're bringing the heat
but then the ones that look too grandpa
i don't like but the buff grandpa ones
i'm just like there's the search
gotcha
grandma but the but the ones that are
more vigorous looking
you search buff grandpa sons are mad
guys yeah yeah they're more like
santa claus looking dudes dude
soa
so how would you guys get away with
murder for 40 years
i wouldn't yeah let's hear this guys
let's everyone hear what he's i bet it's
easier if you live on a farm like that
it seems like it's a that's what i'm
saying i think if you want to get uh
get away with murder it starts with how
dumb the police are over there yeah i
think if you live on a farm you're
probably in an area where the police
force is kind of lacks
not like lapd nypd chicago those are not
good places you guys are discriminating
farm cops but you go to you go to a city
you go to a city where you can run
circles around them
you know that's easy man
like oklahoma yeah what's a day like in
the life of a farm cop
did you do it hey uh i've seen 40 years
it's the farm compositions like this
like all right i'm going to go on duty
and they just go like this
or what someone's tipping over cows
again one of the farm cop is like
becoming a hey helen
i'm coming over for dinner right okay um
so i got to put on my police thing
excuse me ma'am
do you know what happened to your
husband
okay are you going to make the peach
cobbler
like the whole [ __ ]
christmas
it's like stranger things and [ __ ]
they're all friends she said no you're
under arrow it's probably harder too
because there's less neighbors you know
like shits further apart so you're not
going to get a lot of ring camps
the feed is like two people
it's just a cornfield some coyotes out
there just where she's here
everything's [ __ ] far apart and
that's the accents they have in
worcester society and you can you can
hide a body pretty easily if you had a
whole [ __ ] farm
where where i watch ozarks yeah would
you hide it uh i inside some pigs and
they'd eat the eat the thank you joe you
[ __ ] you starve the pigs you take the
teeth out
and then you [ __ ] throw it in there
of the pigs
no of the person that you're gonna kill
or like uh carol baskin yeah baskin
style yeah carol baskin style with the
tigers i wanted that for the movie
snapchat i got to buy a tiger first
so we gotta get a farm you're gonna have
to rent a tiger really
[Laughter]
you gotta rent it until you starve it
though yeah
so in july 2019
brenda's remains were found by workers
in a quote secluded area and uh in a
rough
septic tank not far from her and her
husband's house on the remote grounds of
quaking house farm the discovery was
made after david's nephew took over the
land and brenda's skull was recovered
and she was formally identified using
dna testing
so david then 49 in the 80s is now
accused of having murdered his wife
because he quote wanted her out of the
way so he could resume his long-standing
affair with another woman lorraine
[ __ ] a prosecutor said the
prosecutions uh uh say that it's belong
beyond belief to suppose that brenda
took her own life by climbing into the
septic tank and that she somehow shifted
the heavy lid and put it back in place
above her so that there was no sign of
any disturbance why would anyone have a
really stupid choice
that's how you want to go that's
disturbing suicide by septic tank i know
oh god burrows argued that david knew
about the septic tank so he had her body
in there the whole time and that it
provided him with the perfect hiding
place it meant that he didn't have to
travel and risk being seen making a
suspicious journey around the time of
her disappearance or risk being seen
disposing of her body somewhere else
and of course even if someone did think
to look inside the tank her body would
be hidden from view because of kaka
do you think it's like a thing where um
you know when you murder somebody like
in the heat of the moment or some [ __ ]
and then now that they're dead you're
like you don't want to deal with it
again you don't want to see the body
again because you could have went back
at so many points and just pulverized
the bones yeah and so there's no skull
to be found but it's like maybe he
didn't want to like see it again and
like because he was in such a frame of
mind when he did it that he's like now
it's not he doesn't want to be real
again if i were to commit a murder i
would have to
start with the solution first i would
have to like god damn
watch out for me guys
watch out for me oh what do i do now
with another oh what do i do
that's the worst case scenario because
now your [ __ ] dragon is bloody you
gotta start with okay
my i'm in the event i'm already gonna
end up in another in another's country's
another country another country
okay now part starts traveling and i
reverse engineer all the planners this
is the thing we know about bart he's a
planner but then there's that's a
different thing like premeditated yeah
versus like a crime of passion are you
trying to get away or not dude yeah so
if any of us if bart invites any one of
us into his house or the virgin islands
we walk into his house and the whole
house is covered in plastic we're like
oh we're going to die i hope that's what
you think that's what's going to happen
instead of they're moving
bart's like hey you guys want to go to
work sister shire then while you're sure
let's go i would honestly probably set
up you know like you follow those guys
that make a oven just so they could base
something right then in there like a
pizza guy yeah get a little brick little
brick oven little thing right you just
stuff the body in there is it gonna be
hot enough to burn them i don't think so
all i think is i'm just gonna barbecue
it
and you all got the lighter fluid
and then you light them up you're like
it smells like corpse in here too it
smells like a dead human
there's a lot of places in a farm it's
oregano it's a regular and then outside
a god [ __ ] n says ching chong ling
long
so it just covers up the whole throw off
the center this
when you cremate a human body does it
just need to be at a particular
temperature in order to get past
everything yeah because you can't just
light it on fire google that [ __ ] go to
the public library so it's attracted to
your ip address regular fire will always
leave bones intact yeah yeah
it has to be like that blue fire and you
got to preheat the oven you know what i
mean you can't you can't just throw it
in there while it's still that like a
sub par temperature you can't use a
pizza oven
i should just bake this you get this all
right this one's trying to build the
oven that was trying to preheat it to
350.
you get you get [ __ ] your socks yeah
yeah
and you stuff it in [ __ ] you gotta stuff
the whole thing from the this way and
this way wait wait inside the body
inside the body and you squirt all a lot
of fluid in there too so you gotta
do a dynamite
a human dynamite the inside and the
outside at the same time that's how they
do kahlua pig that's how they do that
you cook inside out they get hot rocks
and they put inside the pig wouldn't you
still have bones after that then but
that's you're compressed and then now
you could do you you gotta go that's
just step one dude like all these steps
yeah oh maybe if it looks like concrete
just mixing into the concrete mix and
then [ __ ] making it
putting a body in concrete genius
people get caught a lot doing that damn
i was just joking
you get caught doing a lot of [ __ ] that
requires you to buy something you don't
already have because yeah all they do is
look at recent purchases that's why you
got to set it all up that's what i'm
saying we have a lot of concrete at home
for some odd reason random spontaneous
you do bart's been regularly buying
concrete for like last three months in
order to
stop asking questions cause he can give
away his whole thing and then people
have no point to subscribe to times 100
how to get away with murder
[Music]
you